only got an urgent call left for this
morning so I can get the GPS video call
back can I just have a brief reason for
the calls it's just after eight in the
morning and the Scramble for a doctor's
appointment is well underway we've had
our phones open for about an hour we've
already got almost 40 calls booked
already Dr lakshman Arya Raj is triaging
his patience
hello hi uh Joe how can I help you today
he spots one he's worried about and
wants her to come in immediately what
we'll try and do is to squeeze you in
and get a blood test done while you're
here yes okay
Dr Arya Rogers Clinic is in birkenhead
in the Wirral one of the most deprived
communities in the country here the m53
is a dividing line if you live on the
right of the motorway heading north you
can expect to die younger than if you
live on the left
the Wirral is one of the most divided
areas in the country both in terms of
economic deprivation and of course
Health outcomes and it's here we find
the biggest Gap in preventable deaths
for any local Authority in England
women here have the sixth lowest life
expectancy at just over 74 years and for
men it's worse the third lowest life
expectancy at around 67. I think the
biggest problem is money really
um
I think there needs to be more more
employment from the point of view of
getting people into work the more can be
done with housing we see housing housing
that's boarded up
which if the bit of money was spent we
could do it up for people who are
homeless or need accommodation we've had
a temperature for a few days and you've
been feeling tired for a few weeks now
Health inequalities are greater here in
the Northwest than anywhere else in
England you can probably throw a cricket
ball from uh from significant wealth to
abject poverty in this area we need more
resources in our health system and I
would sort of put a plea for if and when
those resources come that we prioritize
areas such as these where I think that
extra resource can make the most
difference
the NHS says lessons have been learned
from the pandemic about connecting with
communities we noticed that many people
from some of our social economically
deprived communities or people from some
of our ethnic minority communities
seemed to struggle with confidence to
come forward to engage with public
services you're here to see
um Susan Lockwood she's got some pain in
the back Dr Arya Raj's patients needs
are changing there are more care home
visits reflecting an aging population
with complex health issues hello Mandy
was telling me that you've had a bit of
a pain lately it's arthritis it's just
getting worse and worse and to be honest
it is starting to spread try a bit of
the soup this with widening Health
inequalities will test the NHS as it
faces up to its next 75 years
Joshy Sky News in the world